winter is approaching with tensions with
Russia once again disrupts the supply of
natural gas to the EU in the last decade
Russia and Ukraine have often fought
over gas deliveries during the cold
months sometimes threatening supplies to
a number of EU countries histórico more
the gas goose olay olay the last value
west don't incur the kis kiski forgan
easy if ocular gasps are you see the
lowest ver list more than ever Russia is
the e u--'s top gas supplier some forty
percent of Russian gas is transported
through Ukraine state-owned Gazprom
recently launched the Nord Stream to
project aiming to double exports the EU
and avoid Ukraine as a transit route the
european parliament is now discussing a
new energy security regulation the aim
is to strengthen cooperation and
solidarity between member states it's
the EU taking action to keep the lights
on to make sure that people can heat
their food call their houses go to
school and hospitals keep running across
Europe that's got to be worth fighting
for the new regulation also allows for
mandatory emergency plans between EU
neighbors nobody should ever run out of
gas in the EU
you